depuis la liquidation de la compagnie
fin septembre 2010 est ce bel avion n'a
pas bougé d'un centimètre sur la piste
de l'aérodrome et ses deux moteurs n'ont
jamais pu tourner triste destin pour ce
jet stream 32 de la british aerospace et
airliner de 19 places n'aura volée que
six mois sont les couleurs d'havas air
lancé le 16 mars 2017 c'est ce compagnie
familiale à transporter 12 mille
passagers entre martinique guadeloupe et
saint martin mais faute de financement
suffisant
av ar a décroché brutalement les sorte
au sol une dizaine de salariés sans
repreneur
la structure n'a pu reprendre son envol
à présent il est temps pour
l'administrateur judiciaire de
rembourser les créanciers aux enchères
ce matin un seul acheteur étranger s'est
fait connaître par téléphone le moteur a
été adjugée pour un prix dérisoire
160000 euros à un néo zélandais
il volera bien loin de nos côtes au
dessus de l'océan pacifique